[Música]
mi suegra y yo estábamos trabajando en
nuestro campo cerca del puente
hacia buen día no se veía una sola nube
en el cielo y después hacia las 9:30 el
viento empezó a soplar con mucha fuerza
con un sonido ensordecedor Yo subí a la
carretera para ver que estaba pasando y
rápidamente vi cómo los árboles y las
plantas eran arrancadas de raíz y una
masa se llevaba todo a su paso solo se
veían ruinas
ese domingo por la mañana got ambari no
imaginó que su remoto pueblo situado en
los contrafuertes del Himalaya cambiaría
para siempre
[Música]
el 7 de febrero de 2021 un flanco de la
cima de la montaña ronti situado a 6000
metros de altura se desplomó formando un
tsunami de hielo y roca que recorrería
22 kilómetros llevándose todo a su paso
[Música]
la cascada de barro se precipitaba a más
de 100 kilómetros por hora el resultado
más de 200 muertos y desaparecidos una
de las víctimas fue la suegra de got y
devi que estaba trabajando en los campos
cerca del río del que ahora Solo queda
este Barranco de escombros
buscamos su cuerpo durante más de dos
semanas
revolviendo los escombros con ayuda de
un bulldozer fue en vano y un día un
perro encontró un pedazo de su túnica
negra y amarilla es la vestimenta
tradicional que usan las mujeres de
nuestra comunidad desde entonces vivimos
con miedo de que se repita nunca en la
vida habíamos visto algo así ni siquiera
nuestros mayores nunca habían visto que
una parte de la montaña se desprendiera
y luego cayera es algo que me atormenta
todos los días
en su carrera devastadora El torrente Se
llevó dos presas hidroeléctricas y a
decenas de personas que trabajaban en
ellas
una de las presas estaba situada en la
parte baja del pueblo dos años después
de la catástrofe todavía continúa la
limpieza de la zona en condiciones
precarias
no todos los habitantes están a favor de
estos proyectos hidroeléctricos desde
hace más de 10 años a tulsatti un nativo
de la región denuncia su construcción
antes aquí había un puente lo
pulverizaron parece una trinchera es
como si hubieran bombardeado el lugar
Este es el perfecto ejemplo del
conflicto que opone el hombre a la
naturaleza
consecuencia del cambio climático dos
tercios de los 15.000 glaciares que hay
en el Himalaya corren el riesgo de
desaparecer un deshielo que se acelera
por el aumento de las temperaturas y que
podría provocar nuevas catástrofes
naturales iguales a esta según muchos
científicos
el Himalaya es una cadena de montañas
muy frágil
Y estos proyectos de infraestructuras
serán cada vez más peligrosos en el
futuro
los glaciares se derriten y nuestros
ríos se secan deberíamos Buscar
soluciones para preservar el agua en vez
de lanzarnos en estos proyectos inmensos
que dañan aún más nuestras montañas
Sin embargo a unos kilómetros de ahí
nada parece poder detener la
reconstrucción de la presa
hidroeléctrica de tapo van la obra
también quedó gravemente afectada por la
inundación provocada tras la caída del
glaciar aquí el número de víctimas fue
mayor para atún el proyecto se ha
convertido en el símbolo de esa carrera
desenfrenada por el desarrollo impulsada
por el gobierno Indio
en la Encarnación de la ambición de las
autoridades
creen que pueden explotar el río
sacar provecho de la naturaleza tanto
como quieran
para este proyecto de Central eléctrica
no solo están construyendo una presa
sino que están desviando el curso del
río hacia un túnel en la montaña es un
desastre ecológico En nombre del
desarrollo
la presa de tapón está lejos de ser el
único proyecto del gobierno en esta
región
para atender las necesidades de
electricidad en constante aumento Nueva
Delhi planea convertir a utaracan en el
primer productor de energía
hidroeléctrica del país
dominado por 1400 glaciares y atravesado
por el ganges Y el yamuna dos de los
ríos más importantes del país
este pequeño estado himalayo de 10
millones de habitantes parece contar con
todas las ventajas necesarias según las
autoridades
[Música]
hay 90 presas en fase de proyecto o en
construcción y otras 40 ya están
operativas
una de ellas es la prensa del Aqua
arbiasis ubicada a 400 kilómetros de la
de tapo van es una de las más recientes
en haber comenzado a estar activa para
crear el inmenso depósito de agua
contigua a la construcción fue necesario
inundar el pueblo de loari cerca de 100
familias fueron obligadas a evacuar el
lugar a comienzos de abril de 2022 una
de ellas era la de henares
todo quedó inundado nuestras casas
nuestros árboles frutales los campos que
cultivábamos y donde pasaba nuestro
ganado me dan ganas de llorar cuando veo
nuestro pueblo en este estado aquí nací
aquí pase toda mi infancia ahora no hay
más que ruinas estoy devastado
nariz vivía aquí con otros 13 miembros
de su familia sus ancestros se
establecieron en loari hace más de un
siglo ahora esto es todo lo que queda de
su casa
de este lado había tres habitaciones
grandes teníamos una pequeña tienda en
la entrada allá estaban los baños y la
ducha y nuestra cocina daba un patio
exterior
Todos aquí consideran que son parte de
los daños colaterales de la política de
desarrollo llevada a cabo por Nueva
Delhi
lo abandonamos todo por la producción
eléctrica el gobierno tiene una deuda
con nosotros Porque lo sacrificamos todo
nuestras tierras nuestras casas tienen
la responsabilidad de darnos al menos
una compensación que esté a la altura
del sacrificio
al principio el gobierno prometió que
concedería nuevas tierras a los
habitantes pero se retractó poco antes
de la puesta en marcha de la presa a
manera de protesta varias familias
decidieron quedarse en el pueblo
encontraron refugio en la antigua
Escuela
somos agricultores
esa es nuestra vida antes teníamos la
costumbre de cultivar nuestros propios
alimentos no teníamos que ir a comprar
comida al pueblo Ahora que nos
expulsaron a dónde quieren que vaya
ya no tengo mi granja Entonces no tengo
ingresos
teníamos una vida muy buena y lo
perdimos todo
pero los proyectos hidroeléctricos No
Son los únicos que amenazan el frágil
ecosistema del Himalaya durante la
grabación de nuestro reportaje pudimos
ver la extensión de los proyectos de
infraestructuras en utaracan impulsados
por el Primer Ministro indio
narendramody por todas partes las obras
transforman el valle hay cuatro
carreteras y una nueva línea ferroviaria
en construcción el objetivo es mejorar
la comunicación con el chardan yatra los
cuatro centros de peregrinación más
sagrados de India las nuevas vías deben
permitir que lleguen más peregrinos a
los santuarios hindúes y reducir su
tiempo de transporte estos proyectos
desmedidos preocupan a varios
ambientalistas de la región como Gema
taiani
están construyendo una carretera y aquí
van a ser un puente para unir los dos
costados
para eso aislaron El pequeño afluente
que está situado justo debajo están
destruyendo tanto como quieren y después
tiran los escombros a la parte baja
vichcame
a unos cuantos metros de aquí gemat
quiere mostrarnos otra obra mucho más
grande una línea ferroviaria que está en
construcción
están cavando dentro de la montaña para
su proyecto de línea ferroviaria tienen
que perforar casi 100 km de Túnel eso va
a causar daños irreversibles y
reparables en términos de deforestación
de contaminación de los cursos de agua y
es la primera vez que esta región estará
comunicada por una línea de tren es un
experimento a escala natural que se está
llevando a cabo sin que se haya hecho
una valoración científica previa
para este proyecto calculado en
1400 millones de dólares y a pesar de
las múltiples acciones judiciales el
gobierno indio no presentó ningún
estudio de impacto ambiental está
previsto que los 900 kilómetros de
carretera en construcción se inauguren
en 2024 año de las próximas elecciones
legislativas en el país al borde de la
carretera Germán hace un nuevo
descubrimiento
para ampliar esta carretera hicieron
unos huecos de estas rocas enormes para
dinamitarlas todos los expertos sobre el
Himalaya han dicho durante años que se
debe prohibir cualquier explosión en el
marco de las construcciones que se hacen
aquí las ondas de choque desestabilizan
todo el
Valley con este proyecto el gobierno
indio espera atraer hasta 3 millones de
visitantes al año
distribuidos entre los cuatro lugares
sagrados de la región
el santuario de madrinat es uno de ellos
esta ciudad también cuenta con un vasto
proyecto de Urbanización ilustrado en
este panel
Este es el esquema general para una
nueva ciudad parece que fuera Dubai
singapudo goa y se atreven a utilizar la
palabra espiritualidad durante siglos
las personas que hacían el peregrinaje
al Himalaya venían para encontrar paz
interior no para ver este tipo de
construcciones
[Música]
de abril a noviembre
sus puertas a los turistas de todo el
país que al menos una vez en su vida
vienen al templo dedicado al Dios vishnu
año tras año la cantidad de peregrinos
no ha dejado de aumentar con el proyecto
de carretera las autoridades esperan que
sea posible recibir hasta 30.000
visitantes al día turismo masivo en una
zona geográficamente inestable una
situación que según recuerda al pasado
en 2013 a 40 km de aquí en el santuario
de quedarnas una tormenta seguida de
lluvias torrenciales causó la muerte de
casi 10.000 personas
[Música]
Miren esta multitud si algún día hay un
derrumbe o una tormenta muy fuerte con
una subida repentina de las aguas será
el mismo escenario de quedarnad en 2013
es como si se nos hubiera olvidado lo
que pasó no aprendimos la lección tanta
gente lo único que hace es sobrecargar
estos lugares que estamos haciendo es un
desastre
la reciente es catástrofes en la región
del Himalaya son señales que India debe
tener en cuenta
es indispensable que encuentre un
equilibrio entre su sed de desarrollo y
el respeto por el medio ambiente
[Música]